dass jemand unter der wieder jemanden
getötet spiel sein
hallo ihr lieben freund und herzlich
willkommen zu einem unsichtbaren game
ordner spaß das ganze hier ist crysis 3
in minecraft und ist vor einigen wochen
raus gekommen ich hab es bei play nation
gesehen als sie das gepostet haben und
außerdem auch schon andere youtuber dazu
videos gemacht ezb findet ihr in der
beschreibung und zwar hab ich ja auch
ich bin fasziniert crisis spieler ihr
solltet auch alle kreises unterstützen
euch das kaufen weil naja es ist ein
deutscher entwickler von daher na ja ich
wollte euch allerdings so ganz kurz mal
zeigen warum das hier geht und hier ein
wenig das ganze spielprinzip näher
bringen und zwar einige werden eventuell
den hunter motors kreises can wartet man
erst mal ganz kurz gucken was bin ich
eigentlich
ich bin von craft das land also die hand
sind halt die leute die die cell
umbringen müssen es gibt verschiedene
sell und hunter das was zum beispiel
einzel gerade dem muss sich umbringen
ok adolf mutz was shot balkon kraft ist
schon mal ganz cool weil ich bin
unsichtbar und bin ein handtor die hand
es gibt ein zwei teams hunter und ich
war mal ganz von vorne an ich bin fast
tot
es gibt die zell- und die da hinten ist
ein unsichtbarer ich hoffe mir kann mich
irgendwie beschützen
es gibt die zell- und die hand die hand
da hab ich heute ganz viel mit total
verwirrt geweckt ich bin tot es gibt
halt da bin ich wieder
es gibt die sell und es gibt die hunter
und die hand müssen die zelte töten also
die cell müssen überleben und das ganze
in drei minuten da dürfen die halt nicht
sterben
wir sind unsichtbar wir sind die
hunter und wir müssen diese haltung
bringt die soldaten sind alle sichtbar
das heißt wir müssen sie jetzt finden
und dann einfach nur um bringen dann
gewinnen wir das wir haben
pfeil und bogen und die sell die haben
mit schaufel mit ihnen schießen können
da sind zum beispiel sellings hey ich
habs wieder eingekehrt ich bin voll co
nein also die haben auch so schwer tun
alles mögliche aber ich kann die sachen
von denen natürlich nicht einsammeln
venedig und wenn ich dann töte dich
total op sachen und könnte aber noch und
wirten blauen also das erstmal zum
spielprinzip und server etc findet in
der beschreibung ich hab zwei minuten
wir brauchen das alles zu erklären
das war schon sehr lange so ich bin
jetzt gerade relativ schnell war das ein
jump'n'run skills
das sind ski okay dass noch mehr
unsichtbare also man sieht die ganze
zeit unten wurden wenn leute abgeteilt
ich brauche allerdings da sind zwei
unsichtbare nee das ist ein unsichtbarer
aber wir brauchen leute die ich sagte
mir das mal ganz kurz anders und zwar so
dann bin ich komplett unsichtbar
wir brauchen leute die sichtbar sind
weil die müssen wir umbringen das ist
für die zell halt total schwer zu
überleben weil die halt sind zwar gleich
viele aber die zelle sind halt sichtbar
und das ist halt ein großer nachteil
also wir können die halt sehen wir die
hand naja so ich muss jetzt mal jemand
ein bisschen warum gucken wo wir welche
sein könnten die wand wo wir welche drin
jetzt allerdings nicht ich weiß nicht
also die zell müsse noch 30 minuten
sekunden über leben
ich weiß gar nicht ob es überhaupt noch
cell gibt muss man ganz kurz einfach
gucken
hallo
hallo ich muss irgendwie cell umbringen
finde ich hier welche sich bildungsgrad
meine zweite runde die ich hier spiele
okay noch zehn sekunden
ich weiß ich glaube hier sind gar keine
mehr keines dabei hat auch schon eine
probe dir es also noch ein anderer
unsichtbarer nein verdammt okay okay
sein hepp survive das heißt wir haben
verloren
egal ich packe einfach noch was dran
gameshop und jetzt seht ihr das ist sehr
geil und zwar bin ich jetzt 1 el soldado
ich bin wie alle ineinander das heißt
ich habe eine schaufel die stadtteile
wenn ich damit schlage gehört das
friendly fire sale schildern dass meine
unendlichen pfeile ich find's cool und
ich habe ganz normal ist ja man sperrt
womit ich halt auch schlagen kann
jetzt seht ihr das mal dass ich dass wir
nun die handhabe siegen müssen vorhin
was irgendwie komisch war eigentlich
gewinnen die hunter immer es geht los
und wir haben halt keine verzauberungen
und ich glaube wir haben auch noch ein
leben und wenn ihr erzählt wenn die
kirchen schlagen will steht der friendly
fire ist is built also super durch plant
ich habe auch schon was
vorstellungsvideo eingestehen angeschaut
von den machern von diesem spielprinzip
gefällt mir kocht ihr seht ihr so kann
ich feile schießen ob davon auch
unendlich wir müssen jetzt halt die
leute finden weil die sind unsichtbar
das heißt wir müssen überleben
ich bin doch gerade relativ relativ
offen eigentlich dafür dass wir
überleben müssen aber vorhin haben die
halt auch gewonnen ja man ich hab eine
kirche +25 jetzt zum beispiel bekommen
und dadurch sammelt man sich nach und
nach immer mehr punkte schaut mal
einfach ob ihr leute drin sind ich werde
von allen seiten abgeschossen
man kann quasi als sl soll da die ganze
zeit herum laufen und einfach nur
schießen dass jemand
unter der wieder jemanden getötet ich
bin sein in ein richtiger profi also
spielprinzip machen bisher wirklich viel
spaß
weder bin getötet und ich bin tot
so jetzt seht ihr nämlich weil doch ich
hab mein gott ich komme jetzt als all
things d a
ich werde jetzt nämlich als als wie
heißt es als hunter komme ich jetzt
nämlich wieder weil die cell der job von
den ssl ist dann schwieriger und ihrem
mann ich bin total verwirrt ich muss
allerdings abknallen die lebenden
das heißt als sl zu überleben ist schon
krass schwer deswegen hat mich auch
total gewundert dass dies in der ersten
runde geschafft haben weil wenn die zelt
sterben werden der hunter und wenn die
hand sterben bleiben seit hunter und das
heißt er kann man endlich nur kämpfen
und an alle die an angreifen wollen in
den blumen bringen
dabei ist ich werde von irgendwo
abgeschossen
von da so da bin ich hoffentlich finden
auch ein paar leute
okay die zell müsse noch eine minute
überleben das heißt wer noch eine minute
zeit um die umzubringen weil ich ja nun
in hand haben und was ich machen wollte
war dass ich einfach mal da oben in das
haus rein laufe
weil es könnte ja sein dass da oben
welche drin sind also ich denke mal dass
da oben welche drin sein werden und die
da einfach kämpfen werden
aber nicht mit mir schnell hier war ich
will darauf ok 30 sekunden denke nicht
dass wir das schaffen
dies sind gut mit dabei
hallo man die muster noch irgendeiner
seiner irgendwie nicht unsichtbar ist
ich höre ist wenn pfeil auf mich
geschossen
ich weiß nicht von wo noch zehn minuten
auch jetzt vorbei slf soweit okay gut
meine lieben freunde das war erstmal
crysis 3 minecraft die wollten nur ein
bisschen näher bringen wie immer findet
ihr server ip et cetera unten in der
beschreibung das ist die hier also da
wartet das ist die ihr könnt ihr dann
einfach noch dahinter in warschau einen
moment ich glaube das ist so die server
ich schreib doch mal in die website
schreibe ich euch einfach in die
beschreibung dort findet den ganzen
server apps direkt auf der homepage
und dann will ich sagen ja sehen wir uns
beim nächsten mal